welcome to this video playing rock god
from Canada tryna the English Defence
let's see an early d5 yeah yeah this is
ok you can do that and now a 3 years the
way to go yeah I really they are think
20 miles ages ago played queen age for
in this position is this possible you
know I have a soft spot for those long
Queen moves maybe you can just play Good
Knight c3 taking fos quite tricky quite
tricky is probably an understatement
yeah well Knight c3 looks right anyway
what what else is there III is really a
bit passive not not bad but it's not not
aggressive enough 93 looks fine let's
just briefly consider 93 Queen takes
afford it looks totally bonkers eform
Quincy five hmm
yeah okay the good thing about an
opening like this is you get the guy to
think for a long time after form before
move there okay so he played this Quincy
form e for Quincy five but should be
three twin to e7 it looks it looks crazy
but if I don't take what what was the
point maybe maybe I can't delay this
actually a play Knight f6 first okay
maybe maybe it may be like this and ask
him okay what is your next move if he
goes Knight f3 okay then I'll take but I
have a piece developed at least in the
meantime and nida 3 does not seem so
relevant for the action on the queenside
and not neither three I can also just go
to h5 so mmm yeah maybe what I wondering
i mean i'd be 50 okay if I'd if I take
this now efore Quincy five Bishop e3
going to e7
yeah i'm also i don't know if there are
any in between moves that might totally
kill me now I'm too curious hit up just
giving away the Queen then you have
something to love it I came p.m. and
back to e7 m night b5 there is night a
six yeah he's just playing for
compensation which is probably a
decent-enough IDM but now back to the
aid probably am gone back to the eighth
so night be 5986 mmm maybe a move like
c6 preventing I'd be five for the moment
takes Knight X should be ok
this was cheeky right five Queen was
Queen h4 c4 c5 e78 and I'm I'm always
telling you I'm trying to play correct
Chesser yeah only in the morning you
sometimes have ideas that you probably
shouldn't really shouldn't really play
okay yup d 6 mm here see 595 but I can
always play my day 6 against that I
probably should still do that attacking
you form of course i know the f8 bishop
but nothing to do about that at the
moment yeah yeah I really thought I can
play age six year why not maybe if he
goes Bishop h4 g5 maybe you can take
playing for the pin the pin would be
five
g5 night takes here maybe takes Bishop
takes yeah he will come he will play you
five at the end very likely mm-hm but
he's threatening five of course and
maybe i can i can play knight c6 e5 g5
okay I need to I need to speed up I here
tonight be five maybe okay okay well I
don't mind to give up the exchange but
now we get a totally random game with
both sides having two minutes so we're
playing a sort of bullet style game with
the check with the totally and this this
is not too bad that's not too bad I have
many porns to Bishop said this is okay i
think really not just some practical
point of view but really okay
I have two points for the exchange when
i get f 6 and i get i get very nice
pieces yeah i'll take that all really no
no big hesitation there okay and i go d5
now maybe this first trying to get get
the night away and now d 5 a 94 m come
on
yeah maybe it's threatening here time
morning yeah I am okay tough tough with
this little time
yeah I would love to exchange Queens
relay this would be nice but I don't
don't at the moment see how to do that I
can take be 7 mm I didn't see that
yeah this wasn't a good idea Bishop t2 i
think the position is still totally okay
for black but of course it's very murky
cannot take unfortunately check
then the points are quite dangerous it
really should be quite nice IAM antici
is losing on time light resign yeah but
I think you know by now it should be a
win right yeah minus 5 wow what a murky
game yeah it was more than a bit cheeky
to to grab all this in the opening but
maybe it wasn't so terrible I hard to
tell I mean it looks it looks totally
crazy but need to experiment once in a
while of course the normal move here
would be F fire this is this is just
leading to a normal position from the
from the opening the thing is what
what's a bit different here is that
normally you get to get all this in this
move order and now we had played it
differently and advanced immediately now
a 3 and this allow us the screen age
form I'm not saying that it is great i'm
just saying that it's a difference but
yeah probably probably it is somewhat
crazy what auditorium I mean white
obviously has strong compensation it's
really a question if move like this I
mean it looks it looks totally fine no
don't get me wrong but it's it's a
question if even this is necessary
because the Queen on c5 I probably need
to do this anyway getting it back to the
eighth and then it's not so clear that
the bishop on e3 is actually a correctly
place but ok white white has a definite
compensation here but it still does not
seem to to be totally totally bad
outright computer once the plane I'd be
5 p.m. and roop c4 wow what this is what
he did so 95 96 and rook see form
intending rook a4 a6 oh wow
yeah welcome to computer chess
yeah that's that's released its really
strong the problem is in this situation
at seven is winning the Queen and not
just in exchange let's say I don't know
I play in nothing movie a bouquet for
and he will take a computer will take
here 97 can try that but but what kind
of position is this here there's even
even stuff like that happening very very
strong but it's very tough to play for
for a human and I'd be five okay he
played this I went a 6 h-6 yeah and now
g5 I really thought that this is working
but that's Bishop f600 I all we looked
at mmm ok so I could have played this
and here he would have needed to go to
g3 yeah then I should do that I mean I
know it looks like Swiss cheese this
position but still I need to get rid of
the pin ok this is what I did g5 rook c8
and know this but I don't think that
this is bad for me really I don't really
think yeah the computer is agreeing it
gives like a very clear advantage it's
just like this is your best that you can
do and yeah i just have great great play
for the exchange i mean i have a number
of pawns i'm not even material down term
that Queenie five is an interesting
suggest where this is not bad yeah this
d5 the computer agrees with all with all
that and now the computer wants to
Castle short yeah well this I didn't
consider but it's not bad yeah i
understand i can play Queen g7 all the
time to secure my king yeah probably an
idea I hear the computer suggests Quincy
one I thought about that I thought about
that
that's not not not not bad I have five
piece rock and ton of pawns but it
didn't seem necessary to me really at
the moment okay never did computer gives
it as winning all along but now I need
to take on d failure I forgot really
forgot that you take can take on b7
that's that's bad yeah this is very good
now can check he'll just play that and
black wins yeah and here it is totally
murky again but then he's somehow fell
apart step by step oops Oh rook takes
you six oops rook takes is six hour
looked ok check and here it's very
tricky against the pawns but ok it was a
bullet game at the end essentially okay
thanks for watching